[موسيقى]
بعد أكثر من ساعتين من القتال العنيف ، تم إعدام
جميع الذخيرة التي تم إنفاقها على الكوماندوز الأفغان
بأيديهم
ولكن قواعد الحرب غير موجودة في
ساحة المعركة هذه
بعد ثوانٍ تم إعدام أكثر من اثني عشر فردًا
من قوات النخبة الخاصة.
تم انتشال جثث 22 من الكوماندوز ،
قروي يناشد طالبان
التوقف عن إطلاق النار متسائلا
كيف حالك البشتون وأنتم تقتلون
الأفغان.
تؤكد كل هذه الأحداث أن
الكوماندوز قد استدعى دعمًا جويًا وبريًا ،
لكن لم يأتِ أي منهم يقول أحد سكانه المحليين
ثم استسلموا ، لكن طالبان
أطلقوا النار عليهم
من بين القتلى الكوماندوز سوراب عظيمي
ابن لواء أفغاني متقاعد هذا
القائد المولد.  خلال تدريبه العسكري في
الولايات المتحدة
وكان من المقرر أن يتزوج خطيبته الأمريكية
الشهر المقبل ،
قال والده إن سوراب حاول الاتصال
بالدعم الجوي أثناء الهجوم ،
لكن لم يأتِ أملًا أبدًا في أن
يغضب أي شخص إذا حدث ذلك
لابنه ، أخبرني
لماذا لم يفعل ذلك.  إنهم يدعمون العملية
ولماذا أخبر أحدهم طالبان
بأنهم قادمون منذ أن أعلنت الولايات المتحدة
انسحابها ، وشن
طالبان جرأة
هجمات في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، وأن
المسلحين بذلوا جهودًا كبيرة
لإظهار قبولهم استسلام
القوات الأفغانية.
لكن هذا الجهد العلاقاتي يتناقض مع
إعدام الكوماندوز
قبل أسبوع من المجزرة ،
تم التقاط هذا الفيديو لقوات خاصة أفغانية
في نفس المنطقة تحاول
عملية تطهير
عندما أثبتت تلك المهمة عدم نجاحها ،
تم استدعاء وحدة سورابه في
طالبان وقال عندما يغادر الأجانب
سيتوقفون.  القتال وصنع السلام إلى
متى سيستمرون في قتل
إخواننا في هذا البلد ،
يقول شهود العيان إنهم لم يفهموا
اللغة التي يتحدث بها المسلحون ،
مما يدل على أن المقاتلين لم يكونوا محليين أو
أن بعضهم قد أتوا
من خارج أفغانستان
وفي الأسبوع الماضي فقط الصليب الأحمر  تقول إنها
جمعت ما لا يقل عن عشرين جثة أخرى
من الكوماندوز الأفغان من
فاراب نتيجة القتال الجديد
للرئيس الأمريكي بايدن يقول إنه يؤمن
بقدرة القوات الأفغانية
على الرغم من
الخسائر الجماعية ولكن عندما
يموت الجنود الأمريكيون المدربون مثل الكوماندوز
بأعداد كبيرة.
يتساءل الكثير من الناس في هذا البلد المصاب بالصدمة عما إذا كان بإمكان الجيش
هزيمة طالبان
بمفرده ،
هؤلاء المحاربون الأفغان الشباب المتمددون
ويموتون بمعدل ينذر بالخطر هم الآن
الخط الأخير للدفاع الوطني
بدون دعم القوات الأمريكية أو
المخابرات التي
يقاتلون وحدهم من أجل ذلك.  بقاء البلد